happy birthday to you happy birthday
happy birthday to know and also I find
this to be more of jam I mean it is
Stevie Wonder but when I do want to you
know flex my my vocal cords I could do a
little you know not more than ten
seconds of the birthday okay feel like
I'm really making the birthday episode
about myself I'm sorry I'll stop happy
birthday nice you just like sit back I
truly enjoy the job turning what were
you thinking well I was just teetering
between 25 26 27 because I know there's
like a couple of months a year where you
and I are a year apart I couldn't
remember or maybe the same age like I
just couldn't figure it out and I was
doing the math and it was just I
literally googled how old am i if I was
born in November I did too I couldn't
figure it out and then Olivia confirmed
for me well I am turning 26 today and
every year on my birthday
watch I'm 26 now I guess every are my
birthday I consider to certain I'm a
date were you born I think oh I was born
in the late evening because I was almost
no vembur 7:25 yeah because mom really
one of my birthday to be 11 7 and she
was go that would have been great she
was gonna hold me in until then but I
came out on eleven six and you know what
you were just so excited to get to work
I was jokes I was so excited to see the
world meet my nephew Smee chests go to
the doctor me to notice to jess is an
exciting time for young fact I was
actually delivered by dr. Theo for
Chapman I'm actually I think I did know
that yeah because like you were a
medical marvel the first baby to be
delivered by a dog the first by the way
like I don't want to jinx it but he's
being so good no I know I didn't I did
just jinx it
yeah you're gonna jinx it but we have so
many questions about your boots I'm
gonna get to everything I saw me I
realized so many things about myself
this is the day of realizing stuff it's
only been 10 and a half hours and I
learned so much but I was gonna say
every on my birthday I really do
consider to start lying about my age cuz
obviously that that time comes for
everyone over woman for every woman at
some point in their life and I've
thought about it and I could easily say
like oh I'm turning 25 today but the
problem is like I really am just not a
liar like I don't need any fiber to tell
you oh I just turned 25 it'd be like
actually 26 I'm gonna start
at my age today you know good luck like
I can't complete the lie so what that's
just so funny cuz it's like we're so
similar but I don't have that lying
thing like I'm very good at lying like
easily and naturally something asleep
it's not that I have a problem with
lying it's like I just let everyone in
on the lie you know it's almost like a
joke it's like I'm gonna tell you the
joke because you're just like an honest
like open human being I'm an Ernestine
and also like you have the Botox working
for you so right and I always say like
it's getting older is not sad like
unless you're not on track for your life
you know okay I think that all the time
and unless you're a 26 year old like
still living in the clubs no offense to
you guys excuse me I'm gonna be a 2016
it bums I thought I would be oh my god I
think just hits you know I don't plan on
getting hit by that train anytime soon
I'm gonna be at the club eh is it a girl
girlfriend well you know they say youth
is wasted on the young
and I mean so true because like you have
all this energy but you like have no
money then you get old and you have like
all this money but you have no energy
and like not you don't know how to like
spend it and use it and have fun you
know yeah that's true and you're like
not even like hot so like right no I
mean I was so hot when I was younger
like now I'm just like an old crab I was
sagging skin and tits that go down to my
knees but whatever whatever I love them
I've been thinking a lot now that I'm
like in this medical like not medical
I'm in this plastic surgery Sunnism yes
a doctor but he's not in cosmetic but
now that I'm like comfortable I've wet
my toes in cosmetic surgery and just
have seen the positives of like how it
really like boosts my confidence like I
love my neck I love my botox like dr. DZ
is a life's change
I'm really like now obsessed with
getting my boobs done I'm so obsessed
with it I I'm gonna wait until after
I've kissed what I would get a year or
two with these bad boys and then I have
to go in again right like I fully intend
on breastfeeding assuming you know the
child takes to my nipple and I have a
feeling lilo and like I just think like
I'd rather breastfeed with like real
titties and then get them all
restructured after seven like sucks the
life out of them take them for all they
are and then a fresh look plus that'll
be in like what five seven years from
now and maybe I'll want something
different than I want now anyway so
what's the point
but anyways in this ten and a half hours
of being 26 I've learned a lot about
myself which is that really
like I am and involve now like I wait I
stayed up till midnight would she like a
big dope no no nobody is just as with
means and he was one who told me it was
midnight I was raising hosting sexiest
man alive so the toast I want to saw
that I wouldn't have so late I wouldn't
have even known that it was midnight if
memes didn't come in and usually I got a
call at midnight from someone usually
it's Dana but no shade it's okay oh it
was it Dana it was no one yeah no nobody
no one called me at midnight no text at
midnight it was just like you know what
that's that's called getting older it's
awesome the first text I received was 31
minutes late from my counselor Margo I
was so he's totally gonna be sleeping
right oh he's a she's a grandma then she
like I got I was like oh she's awake so
I'll text her but I wasn't gonna text
you thinking you're asleep and then that
got an answer okay I understand it's
okay everyone is dead one that I
realized I did the right and then I woke
up to a bunch of text messages like I
still got it but you know what like I
was tied his turning it's all I'm saying
I was very much like on the path to
sending you a text at midnight but a
wrench was thrown in my plans because
like I at like 8:30 was like I wanted to
make you a cake so I went to sleep and I
got funfetti cake
funfetti frosting eggs vegetable oil I
didn't have anything I don't even have
the pan I had to go back outside to get
a pan and I was having such a good time
making this cake like I just really
loved like cake I loved baking like I
don't use my kitchen ever this is the
first time I've ever used my oven so my
thing is all news to me so I'm on
FaceTime with Marga when I'm making the
cake and she's making me watch Maggie
Rogers videos which I want to talk about
in a second and I preheat the oven to
375 and it's a new oven I've never used
it and like it's literally going like
one degree to three it took well over an
hour to get to 375 my cake was ready in
the pan I'm like sitting watching videos
finally creeps up to 375 I put the cake
in the oven
and it's not hot looked up and that I
just waited an hour for heating
literally as I was waiting for the oven
to heat I applied for an adoption of a
cavalier like that's how much time add
you have to get this cavalier I then
turned off the oven
tried to [ __ ] limped like fix rid of the
wrench I don't know what how to use oven
these fancy stupid French ovens like me
lay I just want like [ __ ]
Samsung like I want good old Kohl's
Sears ovens
I don't want fancy French technology
that you have to go to friends to get
the part like I just don't want it I
want what is like anime like whirlpool
yeah I just want American yeah and like
big heavy-duty from Sears that I can get
a guy from Sears to come you know bring
in a business so literally after so much
trial and error like I had to throw the
batter away I'm really sorry like I
tried really hard
I so appreciate the effort now that I
think about it I wouldn't know if my
oven works either I've been truly never
ever used my oven so I texted my own arm
like the oven doesn't work and I just
like how have you lived here for two
months and you didn't know that I'm like
I just I don't I don't cook right it
wasn't my birthday yet exactly and I was
really like excited because I have been
holding off on today I like to be like
the fattest day of my life because we're
going to a great meal tonight and I was
like you know what funfetti yellow
yellow cake with funfetti frosting like
I'm going in yeah and I was really
excited for me um and it didn't work out
and now I can't help I think it's a sign
because I weighed myself this morning
and like for the first time in six
months I'm up two pounds and like I'm
really it's sad but lastly like I
deserve it like I literally ate a whole
bag of kick Kennedy's yesterday like oh
yeah I know Sunday and Sunday was a
disaster I wasn't gonna win I wasn't
gonna weigh myself so I kinda period
this morning oh that's that's good yeah
okay the day you got your period is the
heavy well at least for me is the
heaviest that you are Hey
what the [ __ ] was that what Amanda he
and he just made a diagnosis he's so -
oh yeah he had a thought he's like House
you know they come tempers special
special set of skills he's being so cute
right now my leg hurts so bad but I'm
not you know also every one of them to
know about my boots so this was another
way that I knew that I was an adult now
because I plan on wearing like this
really sparkly top with my new sparkly
boots that like I definitely splurge on
and I'm obsessive and they're my new
fall dude and there's such a birthday
booth
and I was just like you know what this
is too much like maybe a year ago I
would have worn it but then I I
I was business on the top today party on
the bottom and I'm almost gonna be party
party but it's just I'm evolving and
it's like I'm always gonna be myself
yeah you're always gonna yourself and
it's like you need people in the streets
to know that it's your birthday right so
like from waist up oh she's just a girl
with a morning show waist down oh it's
her birthday right and like that's
that's us what's up
oh it's election day we down let's
get everyone go to your local polling
station polling Center poll booth you
know but like well in place I think
they're all RAL they're all right just
[ __ ] do it
just those do it so Billy Eichner
doesn't yell at you okay yeah get out
the vote today today is a major day
obviously it's my birthday so it's a
national holiday it's Election Day and
it's also merge day to see me happy
marriage March March March March is
getting all the merge burns burns burns
burns he loves all the marriage burns
burns burns burns burns burns burns
burns burns March noon okay let me see
if he done with the show by new and
sometimes we literally go later oh yeah
no but that's a good lighter lighter
dude and there's no pre-sale for patreon
because we have unlimited quantities for
24 hours you have from noon today till
noon tomorrow to get all the merch you
can dream of it'll take two weeks to
ship because it's all on pre-order we're
not stocking up everyone can get
everything they want as long as they
have access to Internet in 24 hours so
you don't even need a priest up for
patreon everyone just [ __ ] attack
starting at noon I'm so excited to see
pending that some issues on the website
are worked out you know if the
particular she was worth will find out
before noon I'm so excited to watch you
guys get your merge to see you all
wearing it we have such cute design I
don't highly premium whatever what were
you gonna say
I don't know it was the my dementia is
getting next level like I can't I need
to go to school like I need to go back
to school I just have no time between
like exercise the brain just between
like being like a mom to a million dogs
and like I'm almost I'm about to be able
mom to another dog this dog I adopted I
applied for adoption in law unless last
night I just feel like there's a million
things I need to go back to school for
but I just have no time and I need to go
to like online so I don't even need to
go to school I want to like learn how to
do stuff that like I never learned how
to do in school like they don't eat like
technical skills right like I need to
learn how to you know Mark it on social
media you know what I mean but that you
actually know how did you like the one
thing I do you could learn like
Photoshop or like video ed
yeah so I heard Matt Skillshare it's
like it's not really school it's like
online class that's for like specific
technical trades I feel like I can't
believe that like school hasn't evolved
you know yeah to like teaching us like
how to pay our taxes you know like
important life things like Skillshare is
like they like 20,000 classes of like
editing photos video production like
photography like that is stuff we need
to learn how to do it we're running a
business yeah I mean you should get on
something you just got it I did this
frame myself and learn new skills I did
it I'm doing the free trial and I'm
gonna see if I like any of the classes
and then I'm gonna do it it's just like
a responsibility but I have to buckle
down and do it yeah and you can't just
like me going to Harvard Business School
guys join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for our
listeners go to Skillshare comm slash
toast and get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents oh my god that's a
better deal than what I got that's right
Skillshare is offering morning toast
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 20,000 classes for just 99 cents
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
toast and start your two months for each
no 99 cent trial at Skillshare comm
slash toast
honestly like I think it's a really good
thing because like my brain is getting
worse I think it's a really good thing
for me because I need to learn if I
could learn like a little bit more of
like the video production and of things
this show can be like even more premium
yeah we need to just like step up our
video streaming plank abilities yeah
like our content on the content end of
things we're doing a very good job but
we could be doing better also I feel
like cos being extra good today because
he like knows that you applied for an
adoption and he like doesn't want can I
spoil the name of your this dog that you
applied for because it's the best name
to go with oh it literally like made me
do the adoption the dog's name is Thor
Thor and Theo so I follow the Cavalier
rescue association on Facebook and
they're always promoting like dogs that
they just took in and they're always so
cute and I'm always tempted to adopt but
like I know realistically like I don't
know if I could take it on but like I
saw Thor first of all he was a total
Ruby so this brown that Theo is he's all
brown which is like post meets world
exactly if I get another one like I
would want that color and I don't really
want to adopt like a 12 year old
Cavalier which most of the rescues are
because Cavaliers only live to like 14
or 15 it's just like that's too hard
like for for three years and they get
really sick in their old age I just
can't do it but I saw this dog Thor who
was
but he's not even up for adoption yet he
just got into the rescue facility and he
needs to undergo surgery life-saving
surgery it's really sad like he has
intestinal issues me whine and he's won
so I'm like if he comes out healthy
he'll be the same age as Theo which is
perfect
Theo having a companion like to sleep
with in the crate like I can't think of
anything more precious but also more
than what the only it's Theo craves
companionship especially from other dogs
so assuming that the Jones mother
assuming that this other time is like
active and playful like they really like
couldn't make each other sides the
training would be annoying but like I
would do it Ben is like not on board but
he wasn't on board to get the Oh anyway
it's like I'm ignoring him up until like
so I I was literally jamming with that
association it's like when you have kids
and one of them gets old enough to
babysit the others like so Theo will
take care of they'll take care of each
other it's actually less work for you if
they're so occupied with each other and
like leaving them at home alone together
like is better than leaving them at home
I don't know they could get into some
serious trouble no trouble but I was
messaging with the organization and they
were like he's not even being put up for
adoption yet cuz he still needs like go
through all surgery he's really sick
because I put up the adoption and they
let you select which dog you're
specifically applying for and Thor
wasn't there so I put an application I
message em I'm like I just put an
application but Thor wasn't there yet
like I just wanna let you know like I
would like to be considered and you're
like okay but he is like naughty we're
not even thinking about that yeah we
just gotta get him healthy okay I didn't
realize that it wasn't a done deal um
you guys my leg is killing me
look at him oh my god precious gem of a
boy anyways we have such a show for you
today because obviously we have the Fast
Five stories we also will be breaking
down the most important movie of our
time three identical brothers and I
really hoped
three identical strangers sorry I was
thinking about Theo's brothers brothers
and be crazy that's what they are no but
they're triplets so they were all just
like brothers related and they were
identical
three identical strangers I hope you all
watch it last night after our cries our
rally Christ for you to do know that I
we posted on the the toast to Instagram
which is almost 100,000 so make sure to
follow us if you're not excuse me and a
lot of people watched it because we
recommend it and they were shipped to
another [ __ ] core you guys you don't
even know you're about to be more
when we give you our analysis and our oh
and our personal investment in this film
our personal investment in this film
we're about to crack the case wide open
yeah but before we do all of that here
are the fast side stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast does it
feel good to say that ladies oh yeah
yeah oh by the way tell everyone I'm
gonna be here tomorrow no well we were
like going running around because we
booked Teresa Giudice and then I had a
show in Charlotte and it was a conflict
and we found Jeffy come asked her to
fill in and then I forgot that I
literally paid $200 change for you to
move my flight till one o'clock like a
month ago just so I could be here for
Theresa and I like totally forgot about
it so we had to cancel on Joey but I
will be here for 20 sub which is really
exciting and we'll make it up to Joey
sometime oh yeah for sure
Oh Thursday if you have mention know it
is dementia season Thursday I will be
co-hosting with the skinny confidential
it's been a while I'm so excited to like
show her my lymphatic nodes and my flow
on Instagram I think she'll be really
proud of the work that I've done since
she was last here this is like the least
flattering angle I've ever sat in on the
entire go it's like there's like these
shoes ankles dogs it looks like your
shirt is filled with little Theo's they
are but it's lions okay first story
eaters Elba is people 70 of the men and
like he's so tired being such a he's so
tired I'm just putting he'll sleep on my
rose coat okay come grab the punch also
come say hi to yours no no so say my
girl say say say I'm gonna walk him over
to you ooh there he goes call that Margo
he's or he'll just sleep right here oh
my goodness if he does I would die I
love you okay we have to carry on with
the show we broadcast listener